[Music]
hello everyone
i'm alexander the executive director
here at the long now foundation
and i'm joining you here from uh the
interval a very quiet version of the
interval
uh during the quarantine time
and we've been looking at our back
catalog
for uh for things to bring to you um
that were particularly relevant um or in
some cases a
possible escape from this time but one
of the talks that i
feel is one of the most powerful ones
we've ever done uh in many ways
and important uh especially during this
time as
we cross some pretty large thresholds uh
of the pandemic and that one uh is
uh frank ostaseski the founder of uh zen
hospice
uh frank it's so good to see you uh even
if uh
not in person um how are how are you
doing through
this time yeah thank you xander nice to
be with you
and uh and the audience as well i'm
doing okay
i'm doing okay um a lot of learning
going on right now you know
um seeing the tremendous um
kind of partitioning of our country is
difficult
but also being bring witness to some of
the kindness
more kindness than i can remember in a
long time both of these things are
happening
yeah um
one of the first questions that came
through from trey
bochowski asking about
proximity and so much of what you talked
about is really
sitting with people and i think one of
the really profound difficulties of
the death that's happening now is that
these
these people are not dying with their
family and friends and
hospice members but you know possibly
just a very overworked uh hospital staff
in a kind of an emergency mode and um
i just wanted to get your sense of of
how that's how you're seeing some of
that play out
and what some ways that we could
possibly prepare ourselves for it
well of course it's it's an impossible
situation that we find ourselves in
and um you know i i i have a lot of
confidence in people's good hearts
actually
um both in the people who are going
through the dying process
their family even if they're at a
distance and also the caregivers and
clinicians that are caring for them even
if they are in overworked than in
emergency mode as you say
um dying gets our attention and i find
that what's happening now is that even
in these really difficult circumstances
the friends of mine are on the front
lines
they're stopping they're stopping to be
with people who are dying
and um they might not they might not
have done that before but because
there's so much dying happening now it's
really getting their attention they're
stopping
we kind of get it that you know those
folks on the front lines
i'm not so big on the word hero i think
heroes get us in trouble
but i think that um there's really good
hearts there
you know you know xander i i had a
stroke
last july then i had a series of strokes
after that one of them i was with stuart
and ryan actually and
having lunch and then i went to the i
had a stroke and went to the hospital
and when i got to the hospital there was
a nurse in the er
and he was incredibly kind to me
and i it got my attention i said to
myself how did you get so kind working
in er
usually you guys are cowboys and he said
oh i had a good teacher
and he began to describe a mentor that
he had
and the mentor told him how to be with
people at the end of life
how to slow down how to listen more than
talk
and as he was talking about this mentor
i leaned over to abandon my wife and i
said he's talking about scott
and scott was one of my students and so
vanda said to him
oh you're caring for your mentor's
mentor now
and the nurse began to cry
and you know there was just this whole
human being there
it was ordinary in a certain way you
know and i think there's lots of people
like him
um that are with folks at this time of
dying and yeah of course it's difficult
people are dying on ventilators and
isolated alone
away from family but remember many of
the people who died with us at zen
hospice
didn't have family either they had us
yeah um
we've spoken a little bit about
normalization of death and i think
there's
some kinds that are maybe more helpful
than others
uh i wondered if you could expand on
that a little bit
well as i said in the talk i think it's
you know death is in a way ordinary it's
normal it's going to happen to all of us
and so in that way it's really good to
normalize it
but i think there's a challenge now
about normalizing the experience that
we're in the midst of
i don't think this is so helpful to
normalize this i think it can lead to a
kind of moral apathy
we can get overwhelmed by statistics and
numbers and
forget about the individuals the people
that are going through this process so
um i i don't want to i want to stay
sensitized
to this suffering i don't want it to
just become the next thing the nor
the new normal that lacks a great deal
of imagination to me
yeah that's interesting so
normalizing of death itself
[Music]
is one thing but normalizing the
suffering
is kind of another thing you know i mean
i think we have to understand this is an
unusual circumstance
and there are lots of conditions that
are leading to this particular
circumstance besides a virus which is
rampant
and so um this isn't normal
this isn't normal what docs and nurses
are facing in hospitals is not normal
and um and we have to be careful that we
don't become apathetic
when we again when we're struck by these
enormous figures of 100 000 people dying
in our country alone
um yeah so we need to be careful there i
think
but yes death is part of experience as i
say you know it's
life without death is only half a life
yeah
i mean and furthering on that thought i
think you know you're
the first invitation that you had don't
wait i think seems to have particular
resonance now you know we've learned not
to wait too
late to go into quarantine we've also
learned you know as you mentioned
don't tell your loved ones that you love
them too late um
but is there is there more on this don't
wait that is you think is relevant
during this time
yeah i think one of the things that we
should be thinking about this moment is
having those honest conversations with
our family and friends
uh creating an advanced directive which
really
spells out quite specifically what you
want and what you don't want
you know there are choice points now
when we go to a hospital do we go to the
hospital when we get there do we go into
an icu when we go to an icu do we choose
to be ventilated
these are all really difficult decisions
that we have to think through in advance
because our family member won't be with
us in
at that moment likely they might be on a
phone so
write it down and tape it to your chest
if you go to the hospital
yeah yeah yeah well stewart brown you
know the founder of this series
has been very public about his
directives
um and i think they've surprised a lot
of people and and i think
in a good way to um internalize some of
these choices when
when you can um that's been i think very
helpful for a lot of us
yeah he and i have been having that
conversation and it's you know we talked
about
in the beginning remember we were it was
ventilators all the time always talking
about ventilators well the reality is
that
you know we know that the mortality
rates
for those on vendor lice are very is
very high and
people need to be able to make informed
decisions about that
they need to know what the survival
rates are particularly if they have
comorbidities or they're of a certain
age
yeah so let's think these through in
advance and talk to our
health care clinicians as well about it
yeah
um john grinnell uh watching
um asked how do we turn towards
suffering when we're so biologically
programmed to avoid suffering
it's a it's a little bit
counterintuitive yeah no that's a good
question
and to remember that we're more than our
biology
you know uh i think that we have to
understand that as human beings we have
other capacities besides our
instinctual drives we have innate
compassion also
and we can draw on it
you know compassion isn't normally we
think about it as
um relieving suffering taking away
suffering
and that's great if we can do it but we
can't always do it but what compassion
can do is allow us to tolerate suffering
to be with it
until our defenses against it fall down
and then we have
a chance to really look and see what are
the actual causes of the suffering
because it isn't always just the
physical experience
it isn't just the biological experience
our relationship to that
experience is also a cause of our
suffering so we need to investigate that
and see
and that's where we have some choice
yeah
um and marianne gallagher
asked a question i think um that you
probably get a lot is you know
do you have any other more stories from
uh
people's approach towards death kind of
like the red schoolhouse is there any
uh is are there convergences there or
what what do you have to say about that
well
i i think that we have seen
cross-culturally
there are lots of similarities in what
people
either imagine or see in the time of
their dying process
and there's lots of similarities in
those in those
images and experiences i think that
um what often happens is that people
find what is comforting to them what is
familiar to them
that may be their religious training or
their cultural
you know heritages or their family
stories you know they might see mom
or they might see buddha or they might
see a little red schoolhouse
yeah and it's usually often something
that comes from very early in life
you know those memories are laid down on
old tracks in the in our
nervous system and that's often what
shows up for people
i i was having a conversation um with
charles mann the historian and about the
1918 pandemic
and he mentioned that one of the things
that was
really uh written about after that was
the loss of so much of the of an elderly
population that
it felt like they had lost their memory
and their wisdom all at once
and i think you know we're seeing
similar patterns here um hopefully never
on the scale of
that one but um i wonder if you have any
thoughts on
um on losing so much of this memory and
and wisdom
yeah i mean you know in our culture the
wet in the west we
tend not to honor our elders in quite
the same way we do in other cultures
now we're be maybe and until we've lost
what they have to offer us
also people get old without becoming
elders right
um i think one of the things that we
have to look at
you know i i cut my teeth on the aids
epidemic
and you know we now have
millions millions and millions and
millions of people
that have died of hiv and aids and one
of the things that happened in the
beginning was
that there were certain groups of people
that were disposable
gay men ib drug users sex workers
they were not considered valuable
and i think we have to look and see are
we having that idea about our elders now
are we valuing what they have to are we
really taking care of them are we giving
them all the protection that they
deserve
that's a question that's emerging for me
in this pandemic
what happens if we lose institutional
memory what happens if we lose the
wisdom that comes
from generations before us i think
that's not a new normal that i want to
move toward yeah you know it's
especially becoming a question as
people are getting frustrated with
quarantine um and
you know you increasingly hear these
thoughts of like i don't care if i get
it
and um yeah but i care if my
elders get it you know exactly we've got
to think about
our elders and not just elders but
people who have other
underlying conditions this is just
mutual respect actually it's not a
political question
it's a question of heart actually
at least in my mind yeah indeed
uh and that's a good transition to uh
stephen hubbard's question
uh came in um what can we do to
encourage
society's leaders to speak openly and
honestly about death have you had any
luck in this
space depends on the leaders
uh i mean of course i've been speaking
about this
a lot since the beginning of the
pandemic with anybody who'll listen
and i think it's important to recognize
that there are good leaders
there are smart people out there i mean
and there are
people who are lacking in empathy um
you know i i would point to fauci who
did some good work during the hiv
epidemic as well i think he's been
level-headed
and um a calm voice and i'm glad he's in
the room even though
not everybody in the room listens to him
um
i'm not so much for shaming people and
and only reacting with anger i'm
much more a person who likes to
move from being a good example about
what's possible
and i think yes it would be great if our
leaders spoke
positively about this and we can do this
you know we're the ones we've been
waiting
for we can do this leaders are no
leaders
we can make this choice we can take care
of each other this is in our bones
and um and it's now our responsibility
yeah um mary
uh asks um
for some input for uh caregivers it
might be that she's
one of them um but who have
access to you know who may only have
access to
zoom or some other telehealth thing at
this time
have you seen some experience with this
um of
these last experiences really being
mediated by technology
now or yeah i mean it's happening a lot
and thank god we have it you know i mean
isn't it remarkable xander that we have
this they didn't have this in 1918
yeah and you know that we can have
you know these kind of conversations and
still be safe
and keep our loved ones safe that's
really that's important
so yeah sure it's happening all the time
i am speaking to nurses and docs who are
working in skilled nursing facilities
and large medical centers
and yes they can be very rushed and yes
sometimes they can only give the most
cursory
information but i also know nurses that
have stayed out long after their shift
from
holding up an ipad to an elder so that
their family can be with them
i'm happy that we have the technology to
do that and it's even translating into
after death rituals uh funerals and and
memorials that
um people are conducting over zoom
uh it's maybe less than ideal but it's a
way of marking
um this kind of loss yeah
uh ryan phelan um who's
watching online um is asking uh
what what does make a good elder
well that's a whole nother um webinar
we'll have to come back and do that one
but you know she could turn to the guy
next to her you know he'd probably have
something wise to say about this
um you know i think it's somebody who's
learned from their lived experience
who the elders that i know aren't just
those with good theories they've fallen
down
many times you know in zen we have that
expression fall down seven times get up
eight
and i think that's one of the
characteristics that goes when elders an
elder is one who also
knows her heart you know who
understands that that mind can discern
and distinguish clearly
but the heart reveals what's true and
i think wise elders have wise hearts
and so these are just some of the
qualities of course and
we could name a number of others but um
we've all had some contact with the wise
elder somewhere in our life i'm sure
yeah indeed
and brett cox asks
how would you change modern health care
in order to approach palliative care
better what's where are the gaps that
you see there
oh boy um there's quite a few
um well one of the things that
palliative care and hospice care
have in common is that they they
emphasize comfort they emphasize
really not leaving people in intractable
pain
so managing pain and controlling
symptoms are
common to both of those schools of
medicine
hospice care of course is specific to
people who find themselves in the final
six months of life palliative care
doesn't necessarily have that
limitation um
the other thing that happens in both
those systems is everybody works as a
team
and so there's no lone wolfs working no
physician or nurse are working as a lone
wolf
so there's a kind of balance that can be
brought forward an equanimity that can
come forward
from the team from different
perspectives
those are things that i think we could
benefit from in the rest of medicine
[Music]
well let's let's let's just say that if
we did those things that'd be great
yeah be nice to start somewhere yeah um
and um i'm gonna ask just we're gonna
wrap up here pretty soon
um but it's been really great to do this
live um
tim van loan asked i thought it was
a helpful uh closing question
um that these invitations are really
powerful
and helpful um but he could also see
losing them
in in the distractions of life and are
there
is there a way that you suggest to help
keep them at heart
well i think when we let them drop into
our hearts in a way
they become guideposts for us they
become orienting
they become our compass they help us to
orient so that we don't lose track of
them
you know i sit on my meditation cushion
every day
because it stabilizes me it helps me to
regulate but it also
orients me toward my day find some
simple practices
which help you do that whether it's take
one of these precepts or one of these
invitations
or something else that orients you i
have a really simple practice right now
that i'm doing
i go to bed at night and i lie in bed
and sometimes i'm quite scared and
sometimes because of my strokes i have
physical problems and i put my hand on
my heart
and i try to remember the people who are
now in pain
alone at night and i'm very bad at
self-compassion but
compassion emerges with just that
reflection and it spills over onto me
and in the morning i get up in the
morning and i put my hand on my heart
again and i say okay
i choose love today love what would you
have me do today
and again it stabilizes me and guides me
and it's not california these are
central practices in my life that i
think can help orient us toward
living a kinder more compassionate wise
life
yeah keep it simple
thank you and i guess this is a good
moment for me to also mention you know
that
the uh the reason or at least the timing
of the last talk coincided with uh the
release of your amazing book that um
that also covers these topics so people
do want to learn more
i would i would highly recommend it it's
been helpful in my household
um and i i
wrote down a quote during your talk that
um that i feel
is important to leave on and uh this
and i think a very long now quote which
is that the past and the future are just
stories
what is happening now is the only real
experience or true experience i can't
remember exactly how you said it
but uh i think that's a really powerful
and helpful quote
for right now um thank you frank this
has been
really so helpful xander thank you and
thank you too long now for doing this
i mean it's a big gift to the world so
thank you for doing this and all the
other work of course you do all the time
thank you thank you guys um thank you
all for joining and uh
see you at the next event i hope thank
you bye-bye
[Music]